you ready got that I got you mmm hey
people Kevin Hart hair and I'm
comfortable real comfortable I got my
shoes off I got my thighs out why am i
comfortable I'll tell you why because
I'm in Birmingham Alabama it's a city
with good people too who love to laugh
how do I know that because I've done
comedy here several times man this
penthouse that I'm in right now
the first penthouse that I've ever
stayed in I'll add cuz I've stayed it's
a lie I can't lie to you guys
I wanted to stay in this penthouse when
I was coming to Birmingham but I
couldn't afford it so I stayed in the
junior suite it's not about me
that's not even make this about me we're
here to find new talent
the new generation of comedians that are
come what do you don't are you seeing
the phone I'm trying to order room
service put it on that I'm doing intro
you got cable I'm doing intro my
roommate got cable this is not your room
is mine
you're right you're right Your Honor
this is my room what a phone it says
yeah lock that gonna nothing I got
the phone how y'all get keys to my room
that's the question of the day people
are gonna think that we that were
grouping up but that's not the case cuz
I'm a star we're here to talk about the
NIP how much you say I gotta play in our
second row man